[Music]
[Music]
hello humans we have returned and why
wouldn't we dom you've got a new pair of
spectacles i use them for seeing but
only things that are close we've got a
little bit of a jarvis cocker vibe going
on it which is cool because jarvis is a
very cool guy the lead singer of pulp if
you guys don't know pope they're a ben
from sheffield the north of england
fantastic man and he wears glasses like
that and you look awesome
the phone went off there let me have a
look i hope it was your phone it's
javascript wow what's the chance there's
a chance he says i want to live like
common people of course he does the
reason why billy was reaching for his
phone is we've got an amazing piece of
news for you
wait a minute that's the same as the
legal issues
okay i'll go backwards
we are doing our first ever
live friendship onion podcast billy and
i will be attending an orlando
convention at the end of this month is
it the 28th and 29th
it's this saturday and sunday this
saturday sunday and this sunday yeah in
orlando florida we have the date of this
sunday this is
sunday which is
29th
20
i can't believe you don't know the day
twenty oh hold on i'm getting my thing
it will be me the
21st and 22nd right so the 20th sunday
the 22nd what a day it will be
the first ever ever on this planet yeah
or any other live
the friendship onion now what that means
for anyone who's attending or
potentially checking it out later is
that billy and i will make mistakes but
we'll make it look like we were doing
them on purpose right that's kind of
what it is so you can buy tickets billy
is currently scrolling through his phone
to find out the website where you can
buy tickets and the answer is coming now
it's um
the comic-con is called megacorn mega
car it's in orlando
and we'll be doing the friendship on in
on the 26
22nd of this month of me and you can get
tickets at fan expo hq which is for
headquarters dot com fan expo hq dot com
and you'll find everything there for uh
guys buy your tickets it's the first
friendship on your live podcast we're
gonna make it as special as possible you
guys hopefully we'll be able to give us
a tongue twister from the audience maybe
a riddle from the audience we'll be
taking questions
the world maybe we'll have the audience
comes out with stories guys there may be
questions that will definitely be
answered come along it's going to be an
event and like billy said you can get
your tickets from that website and as i
said we might be taking tongue twisters
from the audience and we're gonna take a
tongue twister now are we really from
marcel let's do this very quickly
because marcel said according to the
guinness book of records the most
challenging tongue twister ever created
is this and i'll say it slowly so that
we can then say it fast
the sixth
sick
sheik's
sixth
sheep's
sick
so it's not the fifth
yeah it's not the fifth sheik's
sheep that's sick it's the six
cheeks
sheep it's sick okay three in a row am i
going first that's not you're not going
on the stopwatch oh really you can't be
down ready give me a three two one go ah
three two one go sick sick
right that's one
and three two one go six sick cheeks
sixth sheep's sick six
sick cheeks six sheeps sick six sick
cheeks sixth sheep's sick
i didn't know you had to do it three
times yeah that was 12 45 45 give me the
first time you did it in four or three
yeah i got it wrong then 403 no this is
it three times i i did it lapse
the first time you said it was four
seconds
three four seconds 38 that adds to 12 45
45 okay 12 45 to beat there it is on the
camera billy i'll give you a three two
one are you ready
12 45 to be here we go in three
two one go the sixth sick sheiks sixth
sheep's sick the sixth sick chicks six
sheeps sick the sixth sick cheeks six
steeps no no and you were gonna win it
that was 12 15 and you ruined it okay
that's your first goal that's your first
car i'm gonna give you a three two one
go are you ready things are falling off
are you ready i love that you do it in a
posh scotch accent are you ready yes
three two one go the six six no
no that was 245 and you ruined it this
is your last go no pressure you ready
yes
three two one go the sixth sick sheiks
sixth sheep's sick the sixth sick sheiks
six sheeps sick the sixth sick nose six
sheep's sick oh you got it wrong
well you can take it take it out i mean
it's nice it's not it's not you you got
the time better than mine johnny mine
was twelve foot you got it wrong
you said i don't know but you said
something like this six six six
six
you want one more go are you done with
it one more billy one more you gotta do
over hang on here we go ready
in three
two
one go the sixth sick sheeps six sheeps
sick the sixth sick sheiks sixth sheep's
sick the sixth sick chicks
[Laughter]
it was 11.95 but i think i think we
flogged a dead horse there it was
fantastic fun all right hey we've got a
guest guest we've got a heck of a guess
we'll see you next we'll see you on
sunday at the live the friendship onion
megacon orlando florida we'll see you
there let's bring on our fantastic guest
mister
very exciting
dumb
here we are and i'm very very excited
because this week we have got the
fantastic will wheaton i know
everybody's going to be excited about
that
me including yeah what's that will
i tell you i'm actually excited about
this i told my wife that i was coming to
do a podcast with the two of you and uh
we kind of nerded out a little bit about
it we were both really excited so i'm
super thrilled to be here well would it
would it be fair to say similar to billy
and i would it be fair to say that
you're a kind of card carrying nerd geek
will would that be accurate yeah
absolutely i i would go so far as to
label myself an ur geek
what is that
uh sort of the uh uh one of uh i i come
from uh like if the original geek was
sort of pulled off of the heel of a
greek god or something like that and
then plant it on earth
i'm part of the group of people that
kind of grew up just like really close
to the feet of whoever that person was
um so like as far as modern nerds go i
think that i've been there for a really
really long time like before star wars
and and what in particular would be in
the kind of top you know four or five
geek things that you're into
so like little kid me uh was so into
star trek massively into star trek and
battle star galactica
um and and this this show this
paranormal investigation show from the
70s called in search of that leonard
nimoy hosted uh it was sort of this like
it was the proto show for all those
awful um like like reality shows that
are on uh discovery channel right now
but when i was a kid i was like bigfoot
that's amazing and that sort of inspired
me to
really just allow my imagination to go
crazy
and uh that inspired me to be a nerd for
gaming and a nerd for science fiction
and a nerd for fantasy i've given i've
i've i've been quoted from a speech i
gave where i said that being a nerd is
not about what you love it's about the
way that you love it
that like incredible enthusiasm we have
for things and we cannot wait to find
other people who like the same thing to
like super nerd out about it with yeah
yeah that's that thing that really makes
this giant nerd so like
at the moment i'm massively nerdy for uh
a classic arcade games um i i am i am
just i am i'm obsessed with uh these
youtube channels that do deep dives into
taking apart alternate reality games and
describing uh uh like just real weird um
uh youtube creators who are doing this
thing called analog horror i'm super
into that right now
yeah and it's exactly the same way that
i was like into running around in my mr
spock costume when i was a little kid
well billy billy and i just went to a
convention this weekend we just got back
from it about
three hours ago and billy had drawn a
still image from the 1980s game defender
and
he had said to anyone that showed up
to have him sign something if you can
guess what this game is you win a prize
and no one over the weekend guessed the
game no way so was it one of the eight
bit pieces like the lander or the ship
or something or was it the cabinet art i
act i drew it with a pen and paper
yeah through my memory i just drew the
little mountains you know defender
little ship and i was i was surprised i
thought everybody would get that one
i sometimes do it because atari was my
uh gaming like of choice when i was
younger yeah
so like
we me and don play some games now but um
atari was oh wait i went to a pub once
and they'd
they'd set up all these atari systems
and i was like i will beat anyone in
this puppet any game and i pretty much
did
my whole childhood was sitting playing
that atari with that stick
what you got back there is that um
donkey kong
behind me is uh an uh
it's like a cabinet it's a uh what do
you call it a countertop like a bar top
sized emulator machine uh it has a bunch
of different games and i think it has
like probably has
just a little under 100 games in it but
the ones that i play over and over and
over again are donkey kong and mr do i
just play them absolutely to death uh i
have defender over there behind behind
the laptop where i am now i do have
defender over there um
i am still as incompetent as i was as a
little kid just that wall of buttons was
so incredibly intimidating for me but i
think it's really it's super amusing to
me that you do defender because um the
sound that my phone makes when i get a
text alert from my son is the sound that
defender makes when a lander picks up a
human that little children
lands down and picks it up and takes it
away i found it online somewhere and i
thought oh that's going to be ryan's
text tone that's why i made that for him
that's cool now have you completed
donkey kong because donkey kong is
consistently thought of as being one of
the most difficult games ever invented
right yeah um uh i haven't i um i am i'm
working on it
um
this is a thing that i'm like this has
become a legitimate hobby for me this is
an actual thing that i'm actually trying
to do so imagine that there's a person
who just wants to like really knock
strokes off their golf game i guess and
get really good at it so you know read
the books watch the videos practice
practice practice i'm doing that with
donkey kong in in with the goal of
eventually getting to the kill screen uh
and and i don't i don't have any
illusions about getting one of those
million point scores like those guys do
right
guys
yeah but i've gotten through the level
four elevators pretty consistently now
which is sort of the level of donkey
kong that really blocks uh people when
they're when they're like going when
they're making the move from what the
people in the donkey kong world sort of
define as like moving from kind of like
casual donkey kong players to being like
a serious donkey god player uh but it's
been it's been incredibly fun when i was
a little boy
um i spent the weekends at my great
aunt's house and uh my cousin had an
actual physical donkey kong machine in
1982 whoa and uh his his his dad had
bought it for him and he had different
rom sets so he could take it out and we
could play donkey kong then we could
play donkey kong jr then we could play
popeye and we played these games all the
time jack and i like we just played them
for for entire weekends and i never got
especially good at it i never really
understood it so i thought i'd actually
learn how to play donkey kong i'm going
to learn how to play it the way
a person learns this game rather than
being a 50 year old playing it the way i
did when i was 10.
and that has been i cannot tell you how
incredibly satisfying that has been how
fun it's been and
maybe
there's like an actual donkey kong
machine in my future that i might buy
myself as a reward for you know
accomplishing some kind of big deadline
or something like that
since starting to incorporate magic
spoon into my daily morning routine i've
noticed fewer cravings throughout the
day and more energy to hold me over
until lunch i've been drinking protein
shakes and powders for years but found a
delicious way to get my protein before
and after workouts magic spoon cereal
dom let me give you some facts about
magic spoon cereal 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four neck grams of
carbs in each serving
by the way dom the honey nut flavor has
one gram of sugar
only 140 calories a serving is keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and it's low carb build your own box dom
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter cookies and cream maple
waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the newly
reformulated honey nut flavor that will
be added to magic spoons permanent
collection yeah they brought it back
because it's so tasty and my personal
favorite flavor is the peanut butter so
go to magicspoon.com to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and be sure to use our
promo code onion at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their products
it's back with 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
attention listeners are you ready to be
blown away
you asked for it and they listened our
friends at manscape just relaunched the
ultra smooth package it's back baby your
new favorite tool and complement to the
lawnmower 4.0 to keep your boys smooth
while looking and feeling their best
this specialized groin shaving kit is
here to help you buff protect and shave
your most sensitive areas it's time to
crop that bush of yours and get right to
the roots with a discount just for you
from manscape get 20 off plus free
shipping at manscape.com with the code
onion right these legends at manscape
are bringing the razor back so you no
longer have to borrow your ladies razor
for those precise trims here's the steps
dom okay step one grab your handy
lawnmower four give the boys a classic
trim to your liking get all those hairs
out the way step two crop exfoliator now
this is a good exfoliation keep you
refreshed it will it'll reduce the risk
of ingrown hairs in your delicate places
right step three crop gel now this is
lovely essential oils it's got a spa
treatment every time you shave step four
it's time to shave and this is when you
use the crop shaver designed for shaving
your private places now these three
precision blades extra wide lubricating
strips and pivoting head makes it a
fantastic experience
all three of these vegan cruelty-free
and sulfate-free products are introduced
so that you know your manhood is in good
hands and without compromise it's time
to get up close and personal with the
best tools for the job the ultra smooth
package from manscaped so get 20 off
plus free shipping with the code onion
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code onion
manscape.com smooth out your fellas with
the relaunched ultra smooth package from
the fellas at manscaped your balls will
thank you
since it's so uh it's so front row
center in in the image that we've seen
if you will let's talk about this
bookcase you have behind you because it
is color-coded it is intentionally
color-coded just just give us a little
overview of what we're looking at there
um i am a lifelong tabletop gaming nerd
it is one of my absolute favorite things
i've been doing it my entire life
um
and uh about 10 years ago felicia day
and i co-created a gaming series on
youtube together called tabletop where
we had our interesting friends from the
entertainment industry and from the
youtube space come to our studio and
play tabletop board games with us and uh
as uh the show ran for for a number of
seasons it was uh beloved by the
audience um i think that we can we can
really honestly and truthfully um uh say
that we helped really change the gaming
industry and we really helped i think we
really helped popularize the tabletop
gaming hobby and brick as far as like
bringing it into the mainstream where it
is right now and while i worked on that
show uh i just acquired games at a rate
that um still astonishes me
and um like i'm not i'm i will always be
the little kid who just is cannot
believe that i have like a library of
amazing science fiction books i have a
library of role-playing game books and
on the shelf behind me i have that
represents about a third of my total
game library the other third is over
here off camera and then the final third
lives at my friend's game shop where i
have it in their library that they lend
to people to just come in and play
um just
for uh for the social aspect of gaming
and it's color coordinated because um
i tried it alphabetized i tried it by
like style of game i tried it by game
mechanic like i did all that dumb stuff
that you do you know it's like how am i
gonna figure this out and a friend of
mine does her bookcase this way
and i just thought that looks so
beautiful yeah it's so cool and i'll get
out of the way so you can see like
it gets it goes from like red to blue on
that side and then that side over there
that side of the room is a mess um but
that side it goes black to white with
like kind of the grays in the middle
nice really cool it's one of those
things that and what i love about it is
i've been sitting here doing tons of
press for this book and nearly every
single journalist i talked to is like
okay the interview's over can we talk
about your games for a minute please
yeah yeah
i recently played i've never played it
before i recently played the game uh the
tabletop game labyrinth do you know
labyrinth oh so much fun yeah dude i've
never played it before it seems simple
when you start it but it actually
becomes relatively complicated because
all of the pieces are being moved by
different players i went to yosemite
with some friends and my pal june was
like hey let's see what you think about
this game and i was like i'm gonna go
buy that from amazon immediately i
thought it was so much fun
that's great we took our kids up to uh
up to the lake louise chateau a number
of years ago up in canada up in alberta
uh in the dead of winter and it was
amazing it was below freezing every day
and just like the kind of weather where
you want to sit inside around the
fireplace and we spent the entire
vacation playing sushi go and take it to
ride uh the whole family just the entire
time
i love that i love when i can have
there's games that i like just
objectively but i love when
that game for one reason or another
became part of a special event so it
kind of now that game has a special
memory attached to it yeah and sushigo
is really that game for me i don't know
sushigo it's real fun it's you know
those conveyor belt sushi restaurants so
the game is sort of the game imagines
that you're in that conveyor belt sushi
restaurant and everyone's trying to like
kind of build their best meal and the
way it works is if we're all sitting
around the table we have a little group
of cards in our hands we keep one and
pass it to the left and we just do that
all the way around and we're trying to
collect sets of cards to score and we're
also trying to prevent the other players
from collecting sets of cards to score
so you're sort of like playing this solo
game in front of you you're really
playing a game with the people on either
side of you but then you're also kind of
involved with everybody around the table
um i've made it sound way more
complicated than it is it's a game that
we could sit down i could deal out a
hand of cards and two rounds later you
would absolutely see the game and we
could play all the way through if me if
me and dom walked into your house just
now
and we said okay let's play a game
you've got five minutes to choose it
what game would we play there's only the
three of us all right your wife as well
four of us okay ann is home so and would
want to play with us as well so we could
go for a we could go for a co-op we
could go for a big co-op game uh like
pandemic or uh uh like shadows over
camelot or we could go for we would i
would probably recommend something kind
of light and social where the game gets
out of the way and lets us hang out so
the game is fun and it occupies us but
it gets out of the way and lets us have
a good time so for that i would take a
real social game uh like settlers of
catan probably the star trek edition
because that's my favorite edition of it
or um uh or one of the ticket to ride uh
games there are some that are
specifically for four players so they
play in in a particularly satisfying way
like that but yeah i would definitely go
for like a lighter game or maybe a game
like corkle where you're just laying
down tiles and sort of like creating
patterns and things like that something
like i could teach you any any of those
games i could teach them to you in less
time than it has taken me to tell you
what games we would be playing i'd like
to but as you were telling us it was
like it was like uh
a wine expert talking about what wine
you should have with food but we're
talking about yeah
i i know what that means and that
actually really means a lot to me i
really appreciate that
when people say what games should we
play i always want to find out well what
games do you already like what themes do
you already like and are you looking for
something that is intensely strategic
that's going to be real intellectually
challenging or are you looking for
something a bit more on the social side
that's kind of we're hanging out it's
not super competitive and if uh and
we're not playing for the score right
we're playing for the social experience
of it right and there are some games
that just no matter how light you try to
make them it's just not possible
they absolutely do not support that kind
of gaming well i'm a huge fan of fantasy
i've always i've always been drawn
towards fantasy literature fantasy books
fantasy tv fantasy films i played
dungeons and dragons i played world of
warcraft i convinced billy to play
league of legends and he plays it as
much as i do now and we've been playing
it for a couple of years i think
that what what i loved about donnas and
dragons and what i continue to love
about dungeons dragons is it is so
immersive and there is a lot going on
and the world can be absolutely massive
i have always been trying to look for
almost like
diet dungeons and dragons maybe
something that you could play and finish
over a night with some friends like you
said a little socially thing is there
something that comes to mind from their
will
yeah there are absolutely role-playing
systems that support just in
role-playing lingo we call it a one-shot
just sort of like where we just sit down
we play a thing and then it's over it's
a self-contained story yeah it's you can
do it with d d but you have to design it
yourself which the game absolutely
supports uh it would be something like
we're gonna go raid a tomb
um it would be more of a dungeon crawl
than a story where we have to maybe
solve some puzzles and and save a
village this is like we got to go get
the treasure or kill the dragon or
something like that yeah um uh so that
you can absolutely do that with the
fifth edition of dungeons and dragons
but one of my absolute favorite all-time
role-playing games is a storyteller too
storytelling role-playing games where
it's less about like what did i do with
these dice and what did i do with my
like attack roles and more about what's
happening with this character i've made
up what's happening in this story that
we're telling the first one is a game
called fiasco
the idea in fiasco is you're all working
around
there's a place best with four people
and you're working together to tell a
story you all know what the story is
generally going to be we did this on
tabletop we had him we did an episode of
fiasco that was set in a disco in 1978.
so right away you know what kind of
story it is you get that like dirty
manhattan feeling of the late 70s that
kind of like mean streets feeling and
then the way this the game goes it's
going to end badly for everyone it's
like a coen brothers movie as a game so
no matter what happens no matter how
much you tell the story bad stuff's
happening to your characters and it's
immensely satisfying to find out what's
going to happen and the game gives you a
structure a framework to to creatively
narrate what's going on um you don't
move figures around at all like you do
in some versions of d there's another
role-playing system called dread and we
did another episode of tabletop about
dread dread is a horror rpg and the idea
that the creator uh brought to the
design process was to create a game that
would give the players that visceral
sense of dread and fear and like i don't
want to open the door but i have to that
would kind of go on in a horror movie
and the way dread works is when you are
you there's a game master who's working
the players through the story and
whenever one of the players wants to try
something difficult or if they are
challenged by something that is
frightening or supernatural in the
middle of the table is a tower built out
of jenga blocks you know the game jenga
the balancing game so um every time
you're going to do something dangerous
you have to pull a block out of the
jenga block and stack it back on top so
you're also playing django while you're
telling the story at some point
something horrific happens to your
character and you go to that tower and
the tower just collapses so as you get
deeper into the adventure and the stakes
get higher and higher the tower gets
more and more unstable and that sense of
dread gets more and more just visceral
uh and when the tower falls you're dead
like that your character is dead you
rebuild the tower and you keep telling
the story those are two really great
ways that you can do that kind of like
light idea that you're talking about
where we don't have to get together
every week for
seven months to tell a massive story
like we can absolutely do that and it's
really really fun but if you want just a
quick one evening kind of thing those
are a couple of systems that really
support that by specific design
amazing will hey it's so cool to hear
someone talk with so much passion about
anything but it's amazing to you talk
about games man it's really really fun
it is one of my absolute favorite things
in the world i've never played dungeons
and dragons dom plays and uh he's always
trying to get me to play and we think
we've found a way to do it because
someone was telling us that there is a
star trek version
uh or there's a few but they said
there's a very good star trek one and
i'm a huge star trek fan oh no way i
didn't know that that's cool oh yeah
absolutely i'm very excited to meet you
um is this the moment in this exchange
where i just
where i just vomit on you about how much
i love your work is that is this is this
is it for that to happen that may not go
in your way just now okay
cool so uh i feel like it is appropriate
for me uh just to let that out i'm
really excited i um uh uh i've enjoyed
your work a lot and and actually
um
uh dom we were in a green room together
at comic con years ago you don't know
because you didn't see me i know this
because i was watching you which sounds
creepier than it is um
we were in a green room and i was
getting ready to go do a panel for the
guild and i see across the room holy
[ __ ] that's the guy from lord of the
rings oh my god and i'm like trying so
hard to keep it cool and and like not
not not not be weird and not get in your
space like i knew how much attention you
were getting then and i know what that
feels like so i was like i'm not going
to be that and you started to walk
toward the door you're in a really good
looking suit like you just like really
well put together right and you're
walking toward the room like he's gonna
get mobbed and out of the pocket of your
suit comes this mask like a halloween
mask and you pulled this halloween mask
over your head and disappeared into the
crowd and nobody looked twice at you so
i am relating this story to my friend
seth green who i've known since we were
kids seth is as big a nerd as any of us
action figure nerd collector nerd
massive comic book nerd seth goes to
comic con to get the collectibles and do
all of those things and i was like you
are never going to believe what i saw i
can't believe i'm not doing this this is
such a good idea you put a mascot and
nobody can see you and seth looks at me
and he goes well everybody does that
that's what we all do this is how we go
to comic con and i was like i've been
walking around with my dumb face out the
whole time and i didn't even it never
occurred to me so on that day
i was walking back to the hotel from the
floor and it was the guild was really
big at that time and tabletop was really
big at that time so like um uh people
were kind of like pointing at me and i
was getting stopped a lot and i i just
started to feel a little overwhelmed so
i walked past the booth that was selling
gigantic foam rubber mustaches
with like uh elastic right so i got this
i said to my wife i'm gonna test the
clark kent theory the clark kent theory
is if you put on glasses everybody looks
at you and thinks that guy looks so much
like superman but there's no way that
guy's superman so and you just go on
with your day so i put this giant fake
mustache on to see if it would work
it
100 was perfect i walked the rest of the
entire floor of comic-con all the way
across san diego to my hotel not another
person gave me a second look the only
thing i had changed is i put a big fake
mustache on
so i learned an extremely important
lesson that day
just from being in the same room as you
oh well that's cool man you should have
come over and and said hello but we
don't get that moment again we get this
moment now which is a beautiful thing
yeah i'm gonna be all up in your
business next time we're at a con
together you're gonna really regret that
green chef is a ccof certified meal kit
company green chef makes eating well
easy with plans to fit every lifestyle
whether you're keto paleo vegan
vegetarian gluten free or just looking
to eat more balanced meals green chef
offers a range of recipes to suit your
preferences
with fresh produce premium proteins and
organic ingredients you can trust green
chef is the number one meal kit for
eating well and green chef saves you
time by cutting down all that weekly
meal planning prepping and grocery
shopping there's no waste that's one of
my favorite things about it with green
chef you're reducing your food waste by
at least 25 percent versus grocery
shopping according to a hellofresh
global food waste stuff green chess
expert chefs curate every recipe so you
can enjoy restaurant quality dishes at
home without compromising on taste it's
absolutely true so go to
greenchef.com130 and use the code
onion130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping that's
greenchef.com130 and use code onion130
to get 130 off plus free shipping dom i
love it i love getting that box with all
the recipes and all the food all ready
and those little bags and you've got the
right amount so you don't end up buying
five onions and you only use one onion
it's all perfect and i think of it as a
little game because i'm cutting this
stuff up i'm trying to make the best
meal that i can i love it i'm going to
see a friend on friday night and i'm
taking my little green chef bag with me
and i'll be cooking for my friend over
there you can travel with it as well the
number one meal kit the eating well
green chef
using the internet without expressvpn is
like having a first aid kit but not
keeping it stocked up most of the time
you'll probably be fine but what if you
suddenly get into an accident and
there's nothing in your first aid kit to
help you stop the bleeding
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network whether you're in a cafe hotel
airport doesn't matter hackers can get
on that same network and get your
personal data your passwords your
financial details you don't want that
dom it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone just some
cheap hardware is needed a smart 12 year
old could do it
absolutely your data is valuable hackers
can make up to a thousand dollars per
person selling personal info on the dart
web
crazy what i like the most about
expressvpn you know i'm not very good on
a computer no it's one click you get the
app
you get yourself ready to use expressvpn
press the button turns green done it's
brilliant um and i've been traveling a
lot lately and when you're in these
airports and you're clicking on you've
got to remember if you don't use
expressvpn anyone can get your details
so secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
and you can get an extra three months
free expressvpn.com
and i'm sure billy would be remiss if he
didn't get into some sort of star trek
thing with you because it's an
underestimation to say that billy is a
star trek fan he's a big fan of that
show
do you have a particular timeline or
show or universe that that like you
really that like that's you consider
yours
the next generation
that's so cool i love it it's just it's
i i i always go back to it it's
brilliant i i mean i like i love all of
them really for different reasons
i think the next generation just for me
whatever age i saw i just nailed it for
me and to be part of that what i mean
you were already a star trek fan so how
does that feel i mean what
what how did it happen what was the was
there a phone call there were i i went
through auditions right um uh i i it was
a long audition process and i had to
test for the network and and it was a
whole thing
when it actually happened when it was
real
and i got to go stand on the enterprise
for the first time
i
i was 15
i had watched the original star trek my
whole life yeah uh
i
i owned all the technical manuals all
the like fan created unofficial
technical manuals you'd get at comic
book conventions i had every single one
of them
um i had a mr spock uniform shirt uh uh
that i uh that i had made from a t-shirt
and an iron-on star trek patch like i
loved it so much
and i
i don't know how to describe the feeling
of
going into stage nine and walking down
the corridor into engineering and like
there's the engine you know like there's
the warp core like it's right there and
the lights are on and it's not making
the noise but like
it may as well be real yeah and i just
stood there and
i was just a kid so i didn't do what i
do now which is let's really take this
in and build some memories and please
let me put down some stakes here so i
can come back over time
being in there i just thought
this is like it's never going to be
better than this
i cannot believe that i get to do this
and then
the first time i got to go into the
transporter room and stand on the
transporter pad and get transported i
mean you know practically you stand
there they count the five you step away
they count to five that's it don't tell
us that but when you're a world star
trek nerd and you stand there you know
it's a big deal when i when
when i got to invent
canonically how the enterprise d is sent
to warp speed there's a specific series
of key commands on that ops panel on the
con panel
that i invented
and that is canonically how it goes to
warp speed like
when i stop to think about that
i got to do that
that's gonna be like just that's there
forever it's
you know
like i just gets overwhelmed with
excitement and i feel like i'm just
going to sob with gratitude yeah and
that's it's great to hear well because
you know too many
actors and you know try to be cool about
things and some things are just super
cool and you've just got to see it
you've just got to say i was on the
bridge of the starship enterprise i was
there acting with these guys i mean that
is just just wonderful i applaud you for
that there's just something so
incredibly special and valuable and
memorable uh about working on a piece of
art like like we've had the opportunity
to do
with genuinely wonderful people who
genuinely become
bonded to us in ways that are as close
to family as i think we can get i mean
the
the the eight of us from next generation
talk almost every day
um uh i i don't i don't have any my my
biological parents i have no contact
with i have no relationship with them
and when i need a mom and dad i text my
cast
and ask them if like will you be my mom
and dad right now i wanted like i have
really good news to share and i want you
will you do that for me and they always
show up
i've known sean astin since we were kids
and i asked him did you guys get that
you know like did you get to have that
bond because what a bummer if you didn't
and just like
i know the closeness that you all
developed and that you get to carry that
forward and it really is it really is a
gift and um in my role as the host of
the ready room right now which is the
the online hub for the entire star trek
universe and it's kind of like i do
after shows for every star trek series i
get i get this amazing privilege of
talking to actors from every different
star trek series right now and i'm older
than most of them and the ones that are
star trek fans grew up watching my star
trek so they talk about how excited they
are to meet this guy that was this kid
and i get this privilege to tell them
because i used to be you even for a
minute in my own way
let me just tell you a couple of things
if you'll hear them
that uh some of the original series cast
members let me share with you some i
want to pay forward some of george
takei's kindness i wanna i wanna like
pay forward some of walter koenig's
humor and and just talk to you a little
bit about
what i know your next 20 years are like
if you choose for them to be this way
and overwhelmingly they're like
oh my god please tell me
yeah and to see
the joy and excitement
of i've been interviewing the cast of
strange new worlds and they're all new
to star trek and when i when i talk to
them i gotta be really careful that i
don't inadvertently break my contract
and spoil things
when i talk to them about you know i'm
talking to some of these actors who are
bringing themselves and and their
interpretations to legacy star trek
characters right celia rose gooding
plays uhura but as a cadet like who like
hasn't like isn't fully in starfleet yet
so she has a whole different take on the
character and i was like
so do you know what all this means and i
watched her just light up and talk about
what it means and how excited she is
about it and then she was like and i got
to tell you like what a giant fan of
wesley i was and i was just like i can't
believe any of this is real and like any
of this is happening and it's just
awesome to get to have these wonderful
conversations with people and just like
there were people when i was when i was
growing up who were like buddy be
grateful and love this don't take any of
it for granted and
i wasn't able to listen to all of them
because of all the trauma i had lived
through and everything i was going
through
um at home and
now i have a chance to be the person to
to to younger people today
uh that who was there for me who i
wasn't able to listen to when i was then
and it's awesome
yeah it's it's funny that isn't it it
happens a lot you you see that where
people
kind of wish they could go back to that
moment because they didn't quite live in
the moment
of that time i remember it was one of
the guys in
a big big pop group in britain take that
oh yeah sure well take that we're huge
yeah and then obviously they split up
and it was the biggest thing and then
they were gone for i don't know 10 years
and then they reformed and came back and
one of them said that he said i'm so
happy we get to do it again because this
time i'm actually going to do it i'm
going to be in these moments and meet
these people you know it's so good that
they get that chance you know
to slightly change the subject world
just because yeah we could talk to you
for 25 years and not not be able to mine
into everything that we really want to
ask you but i i have to actually because
it's such
it's such an important movie in my life
and and billy and i get asked all the
time when we were when we were making
rings did we know that it was special
and did we have a feeling on set that
something special was happening
could you just speak a little bit about
how you felt making stand by me and and
did it feel like you were kind of
catching lightning in a bottle a little
bit
it did
absolutely um but i i have to put that
into a lot of context and really qualify
it and you'll understand in a second
i turned 13 during production
i had done
a cup i've done one movie to that point
in my career
and i've done a few tv movies some good
work but
very small in those days
those those that work did not have a
life beyond maybe one rerun
uh or or
maybe it got into syndication but they
generally just they were gone
so stand by me came along and
i thought no one would make a movie if
it wasn't going to be good i just with
that just
beautiful ignorance of youth just
thinking why would anyone waste the time
and money to make a bad movie that
doesn't make any sense
um
but something about stand by me spell
felt special from the very beginning and
i don't know i i can't say oh it was
this it was just something in the air it
was just something that it was an energy
that existed among
all of us
that
nobody could see but everybody could
feel and nobody could describe but
everyone knew was there
and um
i remember thinking
oh this is a this is such a good movie
this is such a good story and people are
gonna really love this
i did not have any idea it would become
one of those kind of
generational films
i did not expect it to be one of those
movies that's probably going to end up
in
when they do those like
you know 100 greatest movies of the 20th
century like there's a non-zero chance
stand by me is on that list and i say
that knowing what it's up against
i felt
like i was doing good work that mattered
i felt like
rob reiner really wanted me there on his
set
and in my personal life in my personal
story
um
i lived in a home where i was the
scapegoat in a dysfunctional family
the man who's my father made it real
clear that he didn't like me and
certainly didn't love me but really
loved and worshipped my younger brother
i had a mom who really only saw me as
a tool to be used to find success in the
industry
um and she
made me believe that being an actor was
my idea and it wasn't
and
when i was on the set
in standby
for the first time in my entire life i
had a father figure in rob reiner
making me feel loved that i never felt
that
and
i think one of the reasons gordy's
performance is what it is that gordy
touches people the way he does that
people feel connected to him the way
they do is i was that little boy
i was invisible in my home i was a
scapegoat i was
dying to be seen
there is no doubt in my mind that if my
father had to choose one of his kids to
be killed in a jeep accident it would
not be my brother it would absolutely be
me like i i know these things and i felt
it all but because i was 12 turning 13 i
wasn't consciously aware of it and i
really believed that i was just being a
really good actor i didn't understand
that i was accessing
real emotions and real experiences and
using them to give life to the script i
didn't get that i get it now and you
know after studying and all that i
understand all of it and it's why i
learned that oh i can do all of that
while i'm being a writer
and like and that's like that's great i
don't need to i don't need to go be on
screen anymore i can do it as a writer
and as a as a creator um cool i'm gonna
do that now um
but when i was on set for stand by me it
was
it was the best every day was great it
was wonderful we had so much fun
um we were making work that we were
proud of we all felt loved everybody was
kind um
jerry o'connell talked about being
scared to death of kiefer sutherland and
i don't remember him that way at all i
remember him as a very sweet man who i
took seriously as an actor but that i
wasn't like really afraid of the way the
way jerry talks about it um
i had
incredibly fun times going to the
aladdin's castle video arcade across the
street from the hotel i figured out how
we could get free games on the burger
time machine in our hotel uh in the
hotel pool and like i had a really
really fun time
uh like doing that it was a great summer
and it's a great movie and i'm grateful
for it and i'm proud of it and um
man the number of people i have heard
from
in the last 20 years
that share with me why it matters to
them why it is important to them just
it's a real gift and i know you guys get
it with people for the whole lord of the
rings trilogy i know that you get it i'm
one of those people and i like it's
you know what it's like when someone
says listen i know that
i'm just i'm a guy but like you did a
thing and it really matters to me and i
don't expect you to care about it the
way i do but thank you for that yeah
i've been on board i've been on both
sides of that yeah yeah i feel you i
mean and
like
i work real hard when i'm on this
particular side of it to really honor it
in the person who's on the other side of
it because there's nothing worse than
being dismissed when you're like when
you're on when you're on that other side
yeah you've opened up to tell someone
someone over this weekend here at a
convention wrote this beautiful letter
basically i think he must have gave one
to all of us but i just read it this
morning when i was getting ready
and uh it's just so beautiful how people
can be touched by that kind of work and
it just it just reminds you doesn't it
that
how blessed you are but also you know
to be very careful with you know how you
talk to people and and you know
to be kind to people behind and stuff i
wanted to be an actor probably from the
age of
i think i think probably nine or ten i
started to get really interested in it
will and yeah so i was studying a lot of
child
performers at around about my age and
the formative
films that i did that was henry thomas
in et and i would learn chunks of his
monologue and the things that you guys
did in stand by me i would spend time in
a mirror
trying to understand what you had been
able to capture in the scene where you
go and buy supplies in the store and the
shopkeeper says hey
you're you're the little brother of the
american football star guy right and you
you have this confused thing of like god
i'm always reminded of my brother's
death and i'm just here to buy
stuff man leave me alone and the
pressures of the world and
i remember thinking how is he able to do
this all he's doing is walking around a
store and picking up a a can here and a
bottle of pop here and a candy bar but
somehow the gaudy
character is always so
heavy you know the the way that you
captured that maybe you were living a
little bit of that
real life well and then just to find out
i want to hear what you say about this
but just to finally just say this little
thing about stand by me and and great
films that kind of have these crossover
moments
it's it it does this they can sometimes
do this like transcendent thing where
you can't fully understand what they've
captured but when i think about stand by
me now and that that monologue at the
end that dreifus does where he says i
never had friends like that again when i
was 12 back when i was 12 12 years old
christ you know does anyone have friends
like that and i i absolutely know what
he means the intensity the profundity
the connection of those friendships in
stand by me is one of the greatest
examples of the intensity of friendships
at that age is an incredible film
those friendships are so important
because they're carrying you from
childhood to adolescence
and and and moving you from like moving
you from there into
uh into that place where your
personality is gonna really start to
form
it's it's um uh i
so i watched stand by me as a kid and
then i watched as an adult with my own
kids
i feel like it's a different movie when
you're an adult than it is when you're a
kid did you have a similar experience
did you notice that that
yeah i mean i think as a kid there was a
kind of gleeful joy in some of the gross
out humor in some of the in the teasing
in in the camaraderie between the
friends the running on the train track
but i didn't pick up quite as much on
some of the sophisticated nuances until
i became an adult for sure
yeah when i noticed that i i i
it was weird it was so i stopped seeing
me
um and i stopped judging my performance
which is just a thing that i did um
that scene in in uh in the in the deli
um
uh
uh it's interesting to me that um uh
that that made a lasting impression on
you
that scene might be
the realist
uh of mine in the entire movie
because what gordy is sort of feeling
and kind of reflecting back to that man
is like
why can't i
why does everybody have to
see me as denny's brother
i don't understand why i'm not like why
am i not enough why am i defined through
him
and
that was my life
i was defined
through
how much attention i was getting by
being an actor
um
and then that only that got that got
real that got worse when all the team
magazine stuff started um
uh that that started after stand by me
but when we were filming stand by me
that was really me i that was exactly
how i felt um
and and um
like
if it matters i'm actually really happy
for you and really happy for
nine-year-old you that you didn't know
what was going on there it means that
you weren't that you didn't have that
you weren't it just means that you lived
in a different emotional space than i
did
i don't know if there's a child
who
has enough experience
and intellectual development to break
that down and understand gordy wants to
be seen here and so he responds like
this
right i i feel like you just put a kid
there who feels that way
that is like 99
of of stand by me is the casting is rob
just finding all of us who are exactly
these people and letting us just breathe
life into the characters so you
to move on from there now
so you you say
now you like to take those kind of
experiences and
you know everything and and be more into
your writing
so uh
well first off you've got a new book
right i do
oh well
tell us about that yeah
i have a book out now it's an it's a
memoir called still just a geek yeah
it's the annotated version of a memoir i
wrote in 2004 which uh started uh as a
collection of blog posts in the very
early 2000s um
uh blogging was brand new and kind of
novel and i was
for the first time in my life just able
to kind of speak on my own behalf and
have my voice heard there was nobody
shutting down my voice and i loved that
and i had a story to tell i had things
that i wanted to say and uh
i said them on my blog and then uh ended
up putting them in a book that i think
like
fives maybe tens of people read um but
but they they they liked it and a couple
uh now two years ago um my editor david
pomerico at morrow reached out to me and
uh through my agent and said listen i
liked this book when i read it about 20
years ago and i wondered if you wanted
to revisit it and reflect on it and
annotate it with your
your responses as an almost 50 year old
to what you were talking and feeling and
talking about and feeling is an almost
30 year old right um and uh and that's
what it is the first half of the book is
that and then the back half of the book
is a series of notable speeches and
essays um that i've written over the
last few years about everything from my
life with mental illness to working on
the big bang theory and working on star
trek uh to be in a dad um and uh and
sort of becoming a writer still just
that's another one to put on the shelf
bills we're we're lining up these books
that we're going to be reading
it's great yeah that sounds like a
really interesting one and what an
interesting life will
i mean some of the things you've done
incredible really really incredible and
it's always great work
so what's next on the writing then
i have at least one solid work of
fiction that is in
the works right now i don't know what's
going to happen with it i have another
thing that i am unbelievably excited
about that i can't wait to get to work
on i am just waiting for uh the gigantic
nameless media company to say okay go
ahead and write that it's all right you
can do it
okay i'm
really really really excited about that
and then i have a third one that at the
moment is just a thing i want to write
about that's just fun and interesting to
me i've been kind of noodling on it for
a few months i don't want to really talk
about the specifics of it because i feel
like if i do that it kind of breaks the
creative
process it sort of short circuits it but
those are the things that i'm doing uh
creatively i'm really uh i'm
very fortunate to
be able to split my time between um
working on these things that i want to
write um and working for the ready room
uh and doing all that work in the star
trek universe um it's uh it's it's just
it's really cool my life is as good as
it's ever been how do people how do
people see the ready room where do you
see that we are on paramount plus in
north america um it's generally on i
don't so because it goes out to a global
audience um yeah i know in america we're
on paramount plus and on the paramount
plus youtube channel and on the
paramount plus um
facebook page
and then internationally
um we're
generally in the same places where you
would watch star trek discovery or star
trek strange new worlds or star trek
picard um but uh probably looking for
paramount plus is the place to go that's
a good question that i need to have a
better answer for i haven't been asking
yet but it's a really good question that
i need to have a much better answer for
so
thank you
your your affection that you have well
as a as the one that you're finished is
that a science fiction
um no the thing that is that that i am
that i'm developing right now uh is a
little near future super dystopian
science fiction
uh uh that and that's still kind of in
the outline process this other thing um
is a semi-autobiographical work of
of fiction um set in the summer of 1983
and it is uh i'd say that i feel like
it's about 78
done
it just need some work so um when all of
this settles down i'm hopeful that my
editor and i can can dig into it and and
see what comes next i would absolutely
love to spend some more time in that
world the time i spent with these
characters in the first draft was really
great really fun um so i'm hopeful that
i can do it again um and i guess you
know we'll just see what happens with
that i don't know and do you do you do
do you take writing
do you approach it like a job do you say
okay it's 9 00 am i'm going in i'm going
to write or do you wait for
oh i've got an idea
there's different phases of it right
there's kind of like different there's
different stages um
and i'm
so
once i know what it is
once i know what uh what the what the
project is i know what the assignment is
i know
what like what i have to do i have an
absolute schedule i get up i have the
coffee um 45 minutes later i go to work
for three to five hours um uh or like
like
anywhere between like two and four
thousand words whichever i tend to get
to first
during that time
i might do absolutely nothing except sit
there and think about stuff or write
things down and throw them away or get
up and pace around the office or
whatever but that i absolutely consider
work time then there's this other thing
that and i don't know what the
psychology of it is but there's another
there's a whole other thing where um
i really just need to like
walk around the neighborhood and it
looks like i'm just walking around the
neighborhood but i promise you i'm not
i'm really working a lot in my head and
there are times where it looks like i'm
playing the playstation and on some
level i am but i'm also really working
on another thing in my head and this is
just a an activity that occupies some
part of my brain that's kind of getting
in the way
so i definitely treat it like a job i
don't sit around and wait for
inspiration to strike i that doesn't
work for me um i need the structure and
and i and i enjoy the structure um and
uh and i
once i'm in that part where it's absol
absolutely happening then it's uh yeah i
get up
and uh it's either the time limit or the
word count limit whichever i hit first
nice have you heard that i don't know if
either of you have heard that thing that
um jerry seinfeld talking about writing
have you heard that
making x's on the calendar and keeping
the chain from being broken yeah yeah
that one and also yeah that one's a
great one and he also he also talks
about in his early days he would be sat
around thinking about maybe writing a
joke but ultimately
lose his sense of concentration and be
watching a movie or watching tv or go
out and meet a friend and he said one
day
he watched a whole bunch of
workmen
come
down the street in the rain and go back
to a set of scaffolds and start working
on a house and he had this light bulb
moment where he was like
well they don't want to go back to work
they don't like going back to work they
would rather not get rained on for the
next five or six hours so what am i
doing i'm in my apartment it's warm i'm
comfortable but i just can't be bothered
applying myself and he said from that
point onwards once he realized it was a
writing day and not a day on set he was
like okay get up 8 30 have my coffee sit
down at nine work till five and i just
love that little light bulb moment that
you had
yeah there's there's a little there's
like just a little
there's a thing where i just become
accountable to myself and uh and i think
about well there's a whole there's a
whole thing in in my new book about this
idea uh i wrote about doing something
kind for future you
so
future you was going to have to deal
with some
thing that you just did right now right
whether it's throwing the clothes on the
floor or not loading the dishwasher or
not taking the trash cans out or
whatever it is or like staying up too
late or like having that drink you
probably should really not have but the
but the drink you had before it's like
you know what would be a great idea is
one more of me like like we've all been
in those places right so um i i built in
this idea of um
uh doing something kind for future you
i'm doing this now so that me from the
future just doesn't have to deal with it
and does it like it's just not an issue
for him and it's all like just all
cleaned up and it's all taken care of um
and like i
i think of like
going to work
as a thing where me in the future is
going to look back and go yeah i did
that work today oh i feel so good i have
a hundred percent earned this game of
donkey kong that i don't have to feel
guilty about at all
like um i i just uh i i love that that
concept and uh and the idea of of
treating yourself as a person who you're
gonna like do a solid for uh
great i'm gonna use that that's
brilliant i had to trick myself into
just being kind to myself and i found
that if if i was like well if i do it
for myself i'm just a selfish dick but
if i do it for that guy
in the future
yeah i'm going to be
just relax watch an episode or something
have a nice time yeah that's brilliant
i'm gonna use that well we should hang
out a little bit because billy will
really will attest to this i am so kind
to myself i give myself treats all the
time i'm always eating
i have extra glasses of wine whenever i
feel like it i am i treat myself like a
little princess we should hang out oh
god that sounds terrific i would love
that i feel like we are two future dudes
who really deserve just a really nice
warm cup of tea
in a quiet corner yeah
it's kind of wild that the three of us
have not actually spent some time with
each other on the convention circuit
because i'm sure you know over the years
i'm sure you get a huge amount of
attention on the convention circuit and
um billy and i and sean and elijah are
doing is it six more conventions in the
next year bills or five i think so yeah
so hopefully we get a chance to see you
will um your odds are pretty good the
odds are good i i i took conventions off
during the worst of the pandemic
i'm sort of slowly re-emerging and just
kind of finding where i feel safe and
comfortable and all of that but when
things are kind of you know not
extraordinary like they are right now um
i try to go between like four and six
different shows every year
and uh i absolutely love them i i've
made so many wonderful friends in the
performer community just people who uh
uh i just took a chance and just saying
like i like your work
you want to talk about stuff
and i've made so many wonderful friends
who like you know we kind of only see
each other out on the road and it's just
it's special i really i've come to
really really enjoy it and it's one of
those uh one of those things i tell the
young star trek actors i'm like you know
if you work
uh if you work hard to have kind of a
family in your cast like we did on next
generation um you're never going to be
alone for the rest of your life because
you're going to get to go to cons if you
want to and you're going to go out and
have dinner with your friends who you
have been in
involved with for 30 years and it's just
gonna be great
um and like
you do a little investing now and oh my
god it pays off
um
it's a really fun world there was a time
in my life where i felt like um uh if i
was if i was doing cons and not like
being a big actor that i was i really
had it in my head that i was a failure
and um
i'm sad that i ever felt that way and
i'm really sad that i ever put that on
myself um because it's
such an incredibly
wonderful
it's just safe environment to celebrate
all the things we love yeah well well
it's it's fascinating talking to you man
billy and i always talk we always talk
about guests on this show and what makes
a perfect guest on this show and we're
always looking for people that are
talking from a place of passion and
gratitude and positivity and you might
be the most passionate grateful and uh
wait what was the last one oh positive
person that we've had on the guests so
far so thanks man
thank you that's a that's that's
extremely kind
i work on purpose to be the person i
need in the world and the person i need
in the world is enthusiastic and kind
um and compassionate and i work i work
real hard to be that guy
if you ever want to be kind enough to
invite me and dom round for a board game
just let us know we'll come round
uh 100 that's happening let's do it
hey man it was great shouting to you
will
thank you this was wonderful i really
enjoyed it that's great fun will i can't
believe it it really is a great guest
thank you for coming on
live long and prosper
[Laughter]
fantastic
well lovely he a brilliant guy and i
have to say i'm gonna take him up on
this offer he invited us over to his
house to play board games i would love
to sit
for an evening and have someone curate
board games for me based on what my
preference is like oh you don't really
like it when it gets aggressive okay you
like kind of fantasy you like a lot of
action you like to kind of help out in
groups and stuff i want to do that so
fantastic he knows what he's doing and i
like i like i mean he's obviously done
amazing work incredible work but it's
now morphed into this other thing where
it's he's doing the work but it's things
that he really loves to do
he's uh he's inspiring now as a star
trek fan
work because there's not a lot that i
know about star trek i know that uh
william shatner was was captain kirk in
the first one and then patrick stewart
in in a new generation well done so will
wheaton's in a new generation the next
generation next direction excuse me is
he a human is he an alien
he's human very very smart young man
the doctor's son
and uh he's only in the first few years
oh
not a different doctor
yeah yeah
but from what i hear
i don't think this is a secret i think
this is not always out and we'll find
out later i think he's in the new
show picard
i think he pops up in that as um
his character from the next generation
was his character in the next generation
fundamental in creating certain things
that move forward in the star trek thing
you know like technologies and stuff we
all uh oh
[Music]
that was the one and also i mean will we
in one of my favorite childhood films of
all time stand by me
amazing performance and it's amazing to
hear
about his journey in life and how that
color is working stand by me
what a lovely man hey guys
we are off remember
we're doing a live podcast in orlando
florida we'd love it to come tickets are
on sale as billy said at the website and
fanexpohq.com you can find it from there
just look for the friendship
and we'll see you next week fantastic
don't forget to send your emails the
friendship onion at cass.com see ya
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my
[Music]